In this unit I'm going to introduce you to 3 computer problems
that will actually turn out to be quite challenging.
And I'm going to do this by introducing you to 3 computer scientists, Alice, Bob, and Carol.
All 3 haven't yet had the chance to learn theoretical computer science or about challenging problems.
Maybe they just didn't have the time or didn't think it was useful to them.
But they're all pretty good practical computer scientists.
So they have experience in programming, and know their way around basic algorithms.
That's also why all of them work in very high-profile jobs.
Alice works in telecommunications; Bob works in biotech or bioinformatics,
and Carol works in finance.
Throughout this unit, you'll learn more about the problems that Alice, Bob, and Carol are working on,
and you'll also meet some additional computer scientists throughout this course.
But let's focus on Alice first.